-I am so happy that
the second season is back.
And this is
very exciting news --
you already got picked up
for season three.
So, congratulations.
-Yeah. I know.
It's a good time.
-It's a very nice time.
-Yeah.
-Season two sort of picks up
right after season one ends.
But one of
the nice additions here
is there is now another assassin
in the show.
For people who don't know,
you are a very effective
female assassin.
-Yes.
-And there's another one
that joins the scene.
Do you enjoy playing, maybe,
a little bit jealous
of a new assassin?
-Yeah, it definitely ignites
a little bit of jealousy
in Villanelle.
How much competition this
assassin is going to be,
we will see.
-Yeah.
-I can't imagine it
to be too much.
-Well, you're a very, like
I said, effective assassin.
And is it true that you have,
in the makeup trailer,
a kill wall?
-Yeah.
-So this is -- Explain
the kill wall real quick.
-I'm sure the actors will
be thrilled to hear this,
by the way.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, so whenever
we had an actor
who was -- who suddenly left us,
we would put a big red cross
through their face
and turn them upside down
and put them on a separate wall.
And we slowly realized
that the death wall
was so much bigger
than the remaining cast.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-So there are more dead people
on your show than living.
-Pretty much.
-How many -- Do you keep
internal count in your head
of how many people
your character has killed?
-I haven't. I haven't.
-Yeah.
It's just so meaningless to you
that it's just like,
"What does it matter?"
-Well, it's just hard to
keep tabs.
And also, like,
we've literally
joined her life so late
in the game that I'm like,
"Can you imagine
all the people prior?"
-Oh, right.
You've probably killed a lot of
people before the show started.
-Yeah.
-Too many to mention.
-You -- We talked about your
family last time you were here.
You still live in Liverpool.
-Still there.
-And that's where
your family's from.
How do they -- Do they like
the show? Are they fans of it?
-Yeah, they love it.
Like, every time I come home,
my dad's got it on repeat
on the television.
He keeps rewatching it.
But they love it.
It's so much fun.
I think they are
a little bit cautious.
Like, they sometimes look at me
and wonder where I get
the crazy eyes from.
-Oh, right.
-They're like, "Okay,
we live with this person."
-Well, I will even say it
myself,
but the first time I met you on
the show, not only, obviously,
is your accent completely
different from the character
in the show,
but you are far --
you're very nice in person.
-Thank you.
-And you don't seem --
-It's all an act.
-One of them's an act,
and I'm gonna
figure it out, Jodie.
-Yeah.
-Your dad works for
a professional football club
over there called Everton.
-He does.
He works for Everton, yes.
-And so --
And I'm assuming that means,
is he's a fan of the team?
-Yeah, well he was born
in Everton,
you know,
like all my family are.
And I used to go to the games
when I was younger.
Not so much now.
But sometimes my dad
would get superstitious.
So when I was younger, if they
were on a winning streak,
I would have to go.
Or if he had a -- you know,
if he had a beard at the time
and they were winning, then
that beard would just continue
and continue
until they lost a game.
-I don't want to
be too negative.
But based on my knowledge
of Everton,
his beard probably
never got that long.
-It's like Dumbledore.
-Yeah.
-No, that's so bad.
[ Laughing ] He's gonna kill me
for saying that.
-You --
This is really cool that you
did this for your parents.
My family, my parents introduced
me to "Monty Python."
I have heard tell that yours
did for you, as well.
And you got to introduce them
to Michael Palin.
-Yeah. I did a drama with
Michael when I was about 16,
and we filmed in Yorkshire.
And we were having dinner
at the hotel one night,
and Michael walked in, 'cause
that's where we were staying.
And my dad was like,
"Do you want to ask Michael
if he wants to have dinner
with us?"
And I was like, "Yeah, sure."
So, Michael came
and had dinner with us.
So, that was, like, my dad's --
-That's really great.
And was it -- Like,
sometimes I feel like
when you have dinner
with one of your heroes,
you end up, like,
not actually enjoying it.
Do you feel like your dad --
-Oh, yeah.
No, I feel he asked every
question that he ever
wanted to ask him.
-Good.
-Yeah.
-That's good, 'cause sometimes
I feel like you clam up
and you think, "I don't want to
be the guy to ask
those questions."
And then you ruin the night
by talking to Michael Palin
about the weather.
-He wasn't embarrassing at all.
I was very proud of him.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's great.
And then another thing.
I know we have this in common
inherited from our parents.
You are a huge
Bruce Springsteen fan?
-Yes. So big.
-That's great. So...
I mean, I knew --
-He's the best.
-I knew he was worldwide,
but even -- even in Liverpool,
The Boss is a big deal.
-Yeah.
I mean, well, I actually, sadly,
couldn't get tickets
to the Broadway show.
-Yeah, I went.
-Yeah, I know.
You're just gonna rub that in.
Aren't you?
-I don't think I rubbed it in.
I think I mentioned it.
-No, I know.
-I was there,
and I had very good seats. Yeah.
-Well, in Liverpool, I was home
a couple of weeks ago.
And my best mate Liv,
she's also a massive
Bruce Springsteen fan.
And we were in a bar, and we
were the only people in there,
and there was one guy
playing the guitar live.
And Olivia surprised me and
requested Bruce Springsteen
and then got me
on her shoulders.
So, we had our own
Bruce Springsteen concert
in Liverpool.
-Oh, wow. I'm sorry,
I just want to go back
and make sure I got
this picture painted right.
You're in an empty bar,
one singer.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-You request Springsteen.
What -- Do you remember
the song, what he played?
-I think it was "Born to Run."
-Okay, so now "Born to Run."
-I heard the intro,
and I was like --
looked at my mate Liv,
and she was like...
-So even in an empty bar,
you have the enthusiasm
of like, "We can't miss
this opportunity."
-No.
-So you get on your friend's
shoulders in an empty bar.
-Yeah.
-How did -- how did
the bar staff react to it?
-They actually,
like, let us do it.
-Oh, really?
-Surprisingly, 'cause this
happens quite frequently,
and we usually
get told to get down.
-Yeah.
-But, no,
they could obviously see --
-I mean, I guess when you
only have two customers.
-Yeah.
"On a crowded night,
we might get you out of here.
But we would love
to have you stay
and, if possible,
order some food."
-Yeah. That's a very good point.
-Congratulations again
on the show.
It is always just so lovely
to have you back here.
-Thanks for having me.
-Come back for season three,
as well.
-Absolutely.
-That's Jodie Comer, everybody.